he's in the first line of the very first
part of the Communist Manifesto Marx and
his collaborator Engels are telling us
that all human history up to this point
in time the time that they're writing
has been what they call the history of
class struggle so their idea is that we
have classes basic organizations of
human beings according to their role
according to their place in society and
that these classes in every society up
to this point have been in a kind of
situation whether they realize that it
or not of antagonism of competition and
conflict with each other well oftentimes
this could be covered over by
institutions of law notions of property
the ongoing processes of production you
could supply distractions by focusing on
wars and political developments between
states between organizations between
peoples but what's really been happening
according to Marx is the interplay
between all of these classes and the
rise of certain ones to dominance and
the fall of other ones from previous
situations or conditions of being on top
so we're going to chart the movement
from ancient or a feudal society and I'm
actually you know oversimplifying here a
little bit admittedly because Marx an
Engel will distinguish between ancient
and feudal society but I want to keep it
pretty simple for this and the
transformation of that society over
generations into modern bourgeois
society the society that we can identify
with the Industrial Age and its
conditions so what Marx and Engels are
doing in this first part is telling a
story now they're making a lot of really
important side remarks along the way
that I'm going to point out for you but
we want to pay attention to the grand
narrative of what's going on
and if you if you want to sum it up in
just one single line it's that the
people who are on top come to be
replaced by a new class of people the
bourgeoisie and it's kind of a you know
maybe a little bit misleading for me to
draw this error with as if the nobility
or the aristocracy simply became the
bourgeoisie that did happen in some
cases historically but as a class they
really didn't become that instead the
bourgeoisie are coming from some of
these lower classes originally they have
less freedom they have less control over
their own destiny and they're going to
become the ones to dominate what's
happening in industrial society so let's
look at what what Marx and Engels have
to say first about ancient and feudal
society
he says free man and slave patrician and
plebeian Lord and serf Guildmaster and
journeyman oppressor and oppressed stood
in constant opposition to one another
carried on a uninterrupted now hidden
now an open fight a fight that each time
ended in some sort of change either a a
revolutionary reconstitution of society
at large or in the common ruin of the
contending classes you can't avoid the
conflict that economic life is going to
bring it back and now notice he says
that in in ancient society and in feudal
society we find a complicated
arrangement of society into various
orders a manifold gradation of social
rank and so he gives the example ancient
Rome where you had the the patrician
class at the bottom you had the
plebeians actually below them you had
the ones that were just called
proletariat and we'll talk about what
that means but then you had a whole
bunch of other people in between and the
same thing happens in medieval society
as well it's not so simple as just those
who have power and those who don't have
power those who are at the bottom there
was an entire grade or ordering or a
hierarchy of ranks and sometimes it's
not so simple as just a bunch of strata
sometimes there can be lateral
Asians as well but I don't want to again
over complicate things too much so what
they're saying is that in modern
bourgeois society they didn't deal they
didn't do away with class antagonism
like he says it is but established new
classes new conditions of oppression new
forms of struggle in place of the old
ones no it hasn't actually done just
that it's it's taken a lot of these
classes that existed in previous society
and imported them into this but the
bourgeoisie end up being on top so he
says our epoch the epoch of the
bourgeoisie possesses this distinct
feature and this is something that we
want to pay really close attention to
although there are going to be other
classes within bourgeois society for
reasons that Marx and Engels are going
to show us most of these classes cease
to matter what really ends up mattering
is the conflict between the bourgeoisie
on the one hand and the workers or the
proletariat on the other hand the
interaction between them in society
because these other classes are going to
you might say fall out of the picture or
they're not going to be part of the
ongoing important developments that are
taking place now one of the things that
often times students coming to this text
for the first time don't realize because
we're looking at it from the vantage
point of the present is when we hear the
word bourgeois we have any associations
with that we often tend to think of
people who are kind of you know boring
who are focused on on making money who
are just you know going along the career
path that they're supposed to go along
we think of people who are conservative
and Marx will agree with that to a
certain extent but the bourgeoisie was
not originally conservative they were
the most radical the most revolutionary
class they're the ones who transformed
society to bring it out of the feudal
era and into the modern era along
that means of productions it's property
relations its understanding of the human
being and its understanding of society
so the first part of this story we're
looking at how the bourgeoisie
revolutionized things so how did that
happen he says well the funeral industry
the feudal system of Industry you always
have to know some way of producing basic
goods and some of that could be you know
a matter of land and agriculture but
there was also some what we call
manufacturing going on in ancient
society and in feudal society if you're
making swords for example or plowshares
you need a Smith who is actually
hammering out iron that iron had to come
from or which somebody had to smelt and
there's probably a whole bunch of other
processes along the way you know just to
store your grain you might need barrels
well there was a person who did that a
Cooper a barrel maker and we can think
of all sorts of other professions that
fit in there as well which had a more or
less elevated status but we're not the
ones who were really in charge in
medieval society doctors for example
medicine was rather primitive in the
Middle Ages but there were doctors and
you could hire one they might kill you
but you could get one that to help you
if you were sick the clergy could could
be understood to fit in there as well
although they overlapped to a certain
degree with the nobility when we're
talking about bishops or or Abbott's or
people like that now what happens
he says the feudal system system of
industry in which industrial production
was monopolized by closed guilds no
longer suffice for the growing lots of
the new market so originally production
is being hearing out by these gills and
the guilds we still have this this today
to a certain extent in certain of our
annual trades where we have apprentices
journeyman and masters now you know back
in the old days apprentices were sort of
the lowest of the low and journeyman
were you know one step up the masters
were the ones who really ran the show
and they'd been in it for a long time
they've learned their craft
they exercised power over the journeyman
and the the apprentices nowadays as
somebody as a union apprentice they've
they're probably actually making pretty
good money but that's because of the
transformation of that in any case a lot
of the manufacturing that was taking
place in the Middle Ages what's
happening in towns and it was happening
on the part of these guilds and it
wasn't able to that system was not able
to provide the goods that were being
demanded by expanded markets why were
the markets expanding well he gives you
some examples of factors that played
into that the discovery of America the
rounding of the Cape the Cape of Africa
they opened a fresh ground for the
rising bourgeoisie the people who could
manufacture things and sell things to
them those who engage in commerce have
been part of the bourgeoisie and the
colonization of America created new
markets as well the East Indian and
Chinese markets trade with the colonies
the increase in the means of exchange
and in commodities general gave the
Spurs these these developments and
navigation and Industry so what's going
to happen from the guild process we're
going to get a different process of
production one that we call
manufacturing the manufacturer comes
from the word for hand Manos in Latin
and manufacture literally means what the
hand is doing so if I'm in a whittling a
piece of truck and making I don't know
maybe I sculpt this into a beautiful
object like the Eiffel Tower if I
actually had talent for that sort of
thing I'm engaged in some
that's not going to be that important
unless I can do this over and over and
over again and sell these things to
other people and maybe have somebody
else who buys them from me and then
sells them to somebody else at a
distance manufacturer is different
because now it's no longer these closed
guilds it's the burgers the bourgeois
the town people from the birds who are
manufacturing things they're hiring
other people to do this work they're
selling the produce and they're able to
supply a much larger market thereby so
the needs of people are actually being
met in this transformation and at first
you know feudal society is able to go
along and act as if things are just you
know just the way they were we just have
some better manufacturing but what's
going to happen is the bourgeoisie are
going to rise to power why because
they're going to become wealthy they're
gonna acquire power within society
they're going to be unhappy at the sort
of conditions that the nobles are or the
aristocracy depending on what kind of
country we have and all these other you
know professions are imposing upon them
this is this age-old conflict between
rank or rank and wealth you know how
those two square off against each other
so this process keeps on going he says
the markets keep growing the demand of
arising even at a certain point
manufacturing no longer suffice is
making things by hand so what happens
then how do we get to the Industrial Age
it's through the harnessing of non-human
power to increase the capacity for human
beings by taking what we call machines
that extract energy from other sources
it could be from human beings running on
a wheel or something like that turning a
crank
but it could also be the harnessing of
fuels and that's going to happen
machines are going to make it much more
efficient for human beings to be
involved in the process of production
which is now no longer manufacturing but
rather machine production says modern
industry takes the place of manufacture
at the place of the industrial middle
class by industrial millionaires the
leaders of industrial armies the modern
bourgeoisie so what does this lead to
that several other developments go along
with it's the development of an entire
world market that we're going to talk
about in a moment so he says the modern
bourgeoisie is actually the product of a
long course of development of
revolutions it's a revolutionary class
in the modes of production and exchange
now here's where marx and engels say
something really important each step in
the development of the bourgeoisie is
accompanied by a corresponding political
advance of that class so in earlier
society there were people who were
higher up than the manufacturers but
they're actually gonna race this going
to decline in status as things go on so
are the professionals that are also
going to decline in status so he talks
about the bourgeoisie putting an end to
all feudal patriarchal idyllic relations
it is pitilessly torn aside the motley
feudal ties that bound man to his
natural superiors that led to a
recognition of nobility and sort of
privileges that went with it and has
left remaining no other nexus between
man and man other than naked
self-interest other than callous cash
payment so this becomes a time of what
we can call
economic humans people always let us say
economic man but I prefer economic
humans because it's all something to
affect the condition of women just as
much as well
everything gets evaluated in terms of
economic exchange what can you sell
things for what can you buy things for
what's the cash value of things the
bourgeoisie are the ones who come to
dominate through the processes that
develop and exchange wealth so he says
we have egotistical calculation results
personal Worth and to exchange value and
in place of the numberless indefeasible
chartered freedoms that the the the
legal system over here and the freedoms
that went with it was kind of
complicated over here the one freedom
that were focused on is that free trade
now he said something else that's really
interesting the bourgeoisie stripped of
its halo every occupation that was
honored and looked up to with awe so
what would these include the physician
the doctor the lawyer the person who
handles the legal matters the priest the
poet the man of science they all become
these professional classes become wage
laborers they work for the bourgeoisie
they work for those who have property
those who own the means of production so
you know if you could think about the
condition of education of professors in
our own time as well and the discussion
about the you know adjunct work that
goes on now this this ends up changing
things radically says the bourgeoisie
revolutionizes the instruments of
production thereby the relations of
production with them whole relations of
society conservation of the old modes of
production what it was that people over
here wanted to do in unaltered form was
the first condition of existence for all
earlier industrial classes so as the
bourgeoisie engages in this constant
retooling re revamping things we see
developments happen so somebody who's a
bourgeois you know in a bourgeois family
and establishes a company a viable
business in 1748 by the time that 1848
rolls around they may be out of business
because other people have come after
them and found a better way to do things
what we call business models or market
models and this process introduces a lot
of instability instability that ends up
essentially wiping away this old society
and replacing it with a very new society
when we talk about globalization of the
key word these days Marx is one of the
first people to really talk about how
that happens due to the bourgeoisie he
says they've given the world market a
cosmopolitan character to production and
to consumption in every country so
because capitalism when we'll talk about
capitalism means in a bit because
capitalism and bourgeois mean modes of
production triumph they end up imposing
themselves all over the world and the
world does become a smaller but also a
more similar place because of them says
by the rapid improvement of all
instruments of production the immensely
facilitated means of communication they
draw all the other peoples into the
realm of civilization but it's not
civilization like this it's civilization
like this he says it compels them to
introduce what it calls civilization
into their myths that is to become
bourgeois themselves so cultures that
are still in a feudal sort of mode when
they're confronted by this the people
who are on top at least or or who have
some degree of freedom are confronted
with an option trying to stick with the
old thing but then you're going to be
replaced you're going to fall into these
low
parts of society or join the bourgeoisie
do things like that start wearing a
jacket in time this by the way is what
has been called by by some people the
uniform of the bourgeoisie you know
wearing a tie wearing a jacket we don't
often associated with those with that
these days you know because we'd have
ten day you know be a little bit more
informal except for you know special
occasions so a jacket and shirt or
something like that but this this was
part of the costume of the bourgeoisie
and it became something it would become
a sign that you could see spreading
worldwide so what else is is occurring
he says the bourgeois the bourgeoisie
has called into existence the men who
are going to end up replacing the
bourgeoisie eventually but if we're
going to get into the greatest conflict
with the bourgeoisie the proletariat and
I'm going to do a little bit of a race
sure here in a moment cuz we need to
talk about the conflict between the
bourgeoisie and the proletariat but I
want to talk about this term proletariat
for a moment Marx didn't originally mean
all people who work as the proletariat
he meant those who were involved in
industrial production primarily in the
cities so he wasn't including you know
necessarily peasants among the
proletariat it doesn't mean everybody
who's lacking property whatsoever either
the lower-class because he excludes what
he calls the rotten dregs of society the
Lubin proletariat the in a rag
proletariat meaning the criminals not
all of them fit into that there's other
classes as well like the petty
bourgeoisie the little shopkeepers and
people along those lines who are going
to eventually find their way either into
the proletariat or or doing something
else and the professional classes are
always just one step away from becoming
the proletariat the word proletariat is
a latin word
originally and it meant those who could
only contribute one kind of thing prolly
sure they had no property they had
nothing going for them except for their
capacity to reproduce now in modern
industrial society the proletariat have
one thing going for them their ability
to work their ability to supply labor so
they are the labor force in modern
industrial society